yesterday we witnessed, uh, one of the most
stunning and cartoonish implosions if a public,
yeah,
figure during congressional testimony that
I can remember and I have seen a lot of examples
of this. I'm talking about Donald Trump's
propagandizing attorney general William Barr,
who testified before Congress before a Senate
committee and imploded in a way that is really
a, uh, a data point in recent political history.
Extraordinarily notable. Now the entire thing
went on for hours and I'm not going to play
hours of testimony for you and there are actually
lots of clips I could show you. Uh, uh, Senator
Mazie Hirono did very, very well. Uh, some
other senators did very well. But just for
today, just to take sort of a tour of one
moment of this testimony, I'm going to focus
in on Senator Kamala Harris is questioning
of bar, which exposed some major problems
in the building evidence against bar as not
a law enforcement official, but just as a
partisan actor in this entire molar report
fiasco who should immediately be impeached
for his role in the management of the Mueller
investigation.
And the release of the report, uh, bar refuse
to even answer clearly like it started and
it was already bad. Uh, Kamala Harris just
asking a yes or no question and bar refusing
to answer whether Trump or people around Trump
have directed bar to investigate specific
people, which we're going to get into in a
bit. William Barr admitted that he made the
decision not to charge president Trump with
obstruction without having looked at the evidence
of the investigation, which in and of itself
there's some justification for, and I'll talk
about that, but it opened the door to bar
suggesting that maybe part of the decision
not to charge Trump was made by Rod Rosenstein,
which is extremely problematic since Rosenstein
was a witness in that investigation. Stunning
conflict of interest. That bar admitted to
a witness in an investigation shouldn't get
to decide whether that investigation leads
to charges.
It's a total miscarriage of justice and I
hate to have to do this last disclaimer here,
but I have to because of the political environment
in which we are finding ourselves. I'm telling
you that Kamala Harris crushed bar in this
hearing because she did. I'm not endorsing
her for president. This is not an attack on
Bernie who I like, just skip it. Okay. If
you're going to write to me and your reaction
to this will be, I'm now a shill for Kamala
Harris. She crushed bar and that's what we're
talking about here. So check out bar squirming,
mealy mouth, unable to even deny that the
White House is telling him who to investigate
and notice that if you're watching Cory booker
is sitting to Kamala Harris is right. The
smirk on his face is the smirk of I am watching
something really, really good happen right
here. Here's bar starting to implode on national
television.
Thank you mister chairman. Uh, attorney general
bar. Has the president or anyone at the White
House ever asked or suggested that you open
an investigation of anyone?
Um, I wouldn't, I wouldn't, uh, yes or no.
Could you repeat that question? I will repeat
it. Yeah. Has the president or anyone at the
White House ever asked or suggested that you
open an investigation of anyone yes or no?
Please, sir.
MMM.
The president or anybody else seems you would
remember something like that and be able to
tell us. Yeah, but I'm, I'm trying to grapple
with the word suggest. I mean, there have
been discussions of, of matters out there
that uh, they have not asked me to open a
investigation, but I have safe suggested.
I don't know. I wouldn't say suggests,
I dunno. Inferred.
You don't know. Okay.
The answer that he doesn't know is stunning
and I don't really get why Kamala Harris moves
on at this point. I would have continued on
that, but I also get that she had other things
to get to and limited time. But it's stunning
and relevant because there are suspicions
that Trump is pushing the justice department
to open investigations into people involved
with the Mueller probe into Hillary Clinton,
Hillary Clinton and associates who knows?
And Bar doesn't deny it here already extraordinary.
And the look on Cory Booker's face, that smirk
really says it all. So let's continue. And
this is really key. Kamala Harris gets to
a really important point. Byron Rosenstein
put out a statement saying that the evidence
led them to decide not to charge Donald Trump
with obstruction, but Camilla Harris wants
to know, did you actually look at the evidence?
And the answer is of course, no.
March 24th summary. You wrote that quote.
After reviewing the special council's final
report, deputy Attorney General Rosenstein
and I have concluded that the evidence is
not sufficient to establish that the president
committed and obstruction of justice offense.
Now the special counsel's investigation produced
a great deal of evidence. Um, I've led to
believe it included witnesses, notes and emails,
witnesses, congressional testimony, witnesses,
interviews, which were summarized in the FBI.
Three Oh two forms, former FBI director Comey
is memos and the president's public statements.
My question is in reaching your conclusion,
did you personally review all of the underlying
evidence? Okay.
Uh, no. We took an extended did, did you get
up? Did Mr Rosenstein? No, we accepted the
statements in the report as the factual record.
We did not
go underneath it to see whether or not they
were accurate. We accepted it as accurate
and made our accepted the report as the evidence?
Yes. You did not question or look at the underlying
evidence that supports the conclusions in
the report? No.
So let's talk about this. Think back for a
second to when the bar letter was released.
The report was sent to bar and within 48 hours
bar was able to say we're not indicting Trump
on obstruction. And at the time we said, how
did he decide so quickly? And Trumpist wrote
to me and said, well David, obviously William
Barr got the report way in advance and had
time to look at all the underlying evidence
in that report. And here is William Barr himself
saying, actually no, he didn't look at the
evidence before deciding not to prosecute.
He did it based on the molar report, which
actually says there is substantial evidence
of obstruction. So I want to be really careful
here. Okay. Because some law enforcement officials
reached out to me because I talked about this
on my live stream last night and said, David,
hold on a second.
It's not crazy for bar not to look at the
underlying evidence. Imagine as rob for example,
wrote to me, imagine a murder investigation
where somebody got shot. The report says the
shooters fingerprints were on the gun. The
attorney general wouldn't necessarily go to
evidence and look at the fingerprints themselves.
They would just assume, uh, because this is
how things work, that the report claiming
the fingerprints were found is good enough.
And that's a perfectly reasonable point. But
there's a couple of caveats here that you
have to think about. Number one, the report
said there is substantial evidence of obstruction.
So when William Barr says, I didn't actually
look at the evidence to make that decision.
Well, the reports said there was substantial
evidence. So when you don't go and look at
the evidence for yourself and you make a decision
that seems to run directly counter to what
was contained in the report, that starts to
be problematic.
But then there's another kind of issue here,
which is the whole point is molar didn't say
that he recommends or can exonerate Trump
from charges on obstruction. Normally when
an ag or a state's attorney, prosecutor, whatever,
get a report, the report says on the basis
of the evidence, here's our recommendation
as to what you should do, indict or not indict.
This was left up to bars. So the standard
is different with regard to bars, responsibility
to look at to, to actually look at the evidence.
Now this is all just a leader because this
gets us to Kamala Harris Sang, isn't it a
problem that you made a decision about charging
the president or not charging the president
without looking at the evidence and bar tries
to play this game of well go ask Bob Mueller
cause in the end he's the prosecutor. I'm
just the attorney general at which point Carla
Harris says, well you did make the decision
not molar. Right. And bar gets visibly confused
and it becomes unclear who actually made this
decision and it is bar digging the hole deeper.
He ties himself up into a pretzel and then
big mistake he mentions we'll actually Rod
Rosenstein was involved in this decision,
which we'll get to in a second. Take a look.
Yeah.
As the attorney general of the United States,
you run the United States Department of Justice.
If in any US attorney's office around the
country, the head of that office when being
asked to make a critical decision about, in
this case the person who holds the highest
office in the land and whether or not that
person committed a crime. Would you accept
them recommending a charging decision to you
if they'd had not
reviewed the evidence? Well, that's a question
for Bob Muller. He's the u s attorney. He's
the one who presents the report, but it was
you who made the charging decisions there.
You made the decision not to charge the president
in the process memo and in a declination memo.
You said it was your baby. What did you mean
by that? It was my baby to let to decide whether
or not to disclose it to the public and whose
decision was it? Who's who
power to make the decision about whether or
not the evidence was sufficient profit. We
make a determination of whether there had
been an obstruction of justice,
prosecution memos go up to the supervisor.
In this case it was the, you know, the attorney
general and the deputy attorney general who,
who decide on the final
decision.
What does is mean? What is language? How does
English Warrick, I'm so confused. How did
I get here and there he said it, he talks
about the deputy attorney general. So bar
opens the door to Rod Rosenstein which Kamala
Harris gets to and this is the key moment.
Okay. And you're going to be confused about
what William Barr says in this next clip because
it doesn't make any sense. Did Rod Rosenstein
decide on prosecuting or not prosecuting Trump
on obstruction of justice? And if he did,
Rosenstein was a witness in that probe. Why
is a witness in the probe deciding about whether
there will or will not be prosecutions? Was
he cleared to be making those decisions? Asks
Kamala Harris and William Barth says, I don't
know. I suppose he was cleared or maybe not.
This is what a liar looks like.
Be the conflict or you know, I haven't been
the only decision maker here. Now let's take
the deputy attorney general Rod Rosenstein
who was approved by this Senate 94 to six
with specific discussion on the floor that
he would be responsible for supervising the
Russian investigation. I'm glad you brought
up that target years experience and we had
a number of senior prosecutors in the department
involved in this process, both career and
nine career. I've, I've, I've, I've read a
lot on this because I have another question
and I'm glad you brought that subject up because
I have a question about that. Earlier today
in response to Senator Graham, you said quote
that you consulted with Rosenstein constantly
unquote with respect to the special counsel's
investigation report, but Deputy Attorney
General Rosenstein is also a key witness in
the firing of FBI Director Comey. Did you
consult with Dee? I'm not finished yet. Did
you consult with Doj Ethics officials before
you enlisted Rod Rosenstein to participate
in a charging decision for an investigation?
The subject of which he is also a witness?
My understanding was that he had been cleared
already to participate in it. So you had consulted
with them and they cleared it? No, I think
they cleared it when he's, when he took over
the investigation. Did you consider understanding?
I am. You don't know whether he's been cleared
of a conflict of interest. It wouldn't be
participating if there was a conflict of interest.
So you're saying that it did not need to be
reviewed by the career ethics officials in
your office? Believe it, I believe, well,
I believe it was reviewed and I find out this
seems to be a bit of a flip flop because when
the president's supporters were challenged
by those in this case is that you're not answering
the question directly. Right. Did the ethics
officials in your office in the Department
of Justice review the appropriateness of Rod
Rosenstein being a part of making a charging
decision on an investigation which he is also
a witness in? Yeah. So as I said, my understanding
was he had been cleared and he had been cleared
before I arrived.
Endlessly. Endlessly stunning. This is what
a liar looks like. Bars, a hatchet man. He
did what he was brought in to do. It's very
clear now and he has to be removed. Let me
know what you think. Uh, I'm on Twitter at
d pacman. The show is on Twitter at David
talking show. I want to hear from you about